mais
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de vip pour ce groupe
aujourd'hui bamba cei est à mes côtés le
basketteur bonjour marc bonjour médiane
alors vous êtes basketteurs vous avait
42 ans le basket c'est votre passion
c'est ça où tout a commencé c'est au
sénégal c'était au sénégal quand j'avais
14 ans j'ai commencé le basket donc toi
y avait le jure avec michael jordan et
toute la dream team c'est ça et donc du
coup ça m'a donné goût et j'ai commencé
à jouer dehors et voilà c'est fait a
commencé à partir de là vous avez
commencé assez tardivement finalement
oui j'ai commencé assez tardivement en
place et je suis issu d'une famille
basque et a donc donc voilà ça vous a
donné envie sans me donner envie et le
fait qu' il est michael jordan l'une de
vos idoles en jeu oui c'est dans cette
danse est et qu'il savait encore plus
motivé à réussir dans le basket
exactement c'est ça donc on les suivait
partons donc voilà et on essaye de
reproduire dans un geste et tout ça donc
c'est ça qui m'a donné envie de
commencer le basket après avoir commencé
le basket à 14 ans vous disiez a
précédemment vous êtes arrivé en france
vous avez joué à trappes pendant cette
année
voilà c'est qu'ils ont un petit peu
cette scène a en fait quand j'ai
commencé et déjà dû au sénégal j'ai été
formé à l us gorée que j'ai fait deux
ans et après je suis parti à
la ccdh baup et à l'âge de 21 ans
j'étais sélectionné en équipe nationale
donc et après je suis venu en france et
quand je suis arrivé en france j'étais à
chocolat réserver avant le commissaire
nasser qui attrapent
fait appel à voir donc c'est à partir de
deux que je suis
à trappes pourquoi trappe ben parce que
nasser m'avait contacté parce que je
jouais un niveau qui n'était pas au
niveau du tout donc j'ai j'avais
donc de niveau
était trop faible
pour moi et donc nécessairement
suggérer de signer à trappes qui était
un club en plein essor à ce moment là
qu'ils avaient de fortes ambitions
voilà diop qui a été jusqu'à la
nationale une voilà c'est ça donc après
je suis arrivé à trappes que j'ai réussi
à gagner ma place c'était pas évident de
devenir attrape parce que déjà il y
avait une base solide qui étaient là et
c'était une grande équipe et donc du
coup je me suis intégré et j'ai fait ma
place donc voilà je suis resté sept ans
donc vous êtes resté 7 en septembre
qu'est ce que vous retenez de cette
aventure
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses en
fait je me suis formé plus attrape parce
qu'il y avait le coach fabrice calmon
qui était qui était un formateur qui qui
était entraîneur à l'époque donc les
marques plutôt que les bases il m'a
rappelé toutes les bases la formation
française qu'a donc du coup après je me
suis adapté et voilà et j'ai l'impession
journalistes est ce qu'un soutien en
particulier qui vous a marqué c'est la
montée la montée en nationale 2 pourquoi
ben parce que c'est parce que quand je
suis arrivé à trappes on est resté au
moins
55 ans est remonté à chaque fois les
limites et donc
la dame
l'année où on a monté c'était c'était
formidable parce que
tout le travail a payé est ce qu'on peut
dire que c'était vos plus belles allait
peut-être ou est-ce qui n'a eu d'autre
après derrière après derrière il y en a
eu d'autres
c'est comme quand j'ai quitté quitté
attrape j'étais j'ai signé à revendre
dans le 92 et donc là bas j'ai fait 11
ans 11 ans 11 ans 11 ans avance et
malheureusement n'est pas voté mais on
avait des bonnes équipes et toutes les
années on a on était dans le podium on
n'avait pas monté et j'ai pris du
plaisir et tout ça et j'ai fini mes
remarques de soin de ceux de l'équipe de
france oui vous êtes un score trappe
aussi vous étiez un square mémoire est
devenu encore plus coureur avant voilà
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça je rattrape
aussi aussi pareil j'ai ajouté un
scoreur donc j'ai défendue a défendu
aussi et à
donc du coup la défense après ça te
donne envie de scorer de passer un cap
au scoring donc je suis devenu plus
adroit que voilà et attrapes j'ai
utilisé chaque année meilleur marqueur
de l'équipe est ce que pour vous c'est
naturel de marquer des paniers ou est-ce
que vous êtes forcé à devenir scoreur je
me suis forcé à devient square c'est pas
c'est pas facile il ya beaucoup de
travail il ya beaucoup de travail
surtout à mon poste
intérieur des fois il ya plus costaud
comment un plus grand commun ont failli
fait à 3 ou faut être rapide et physique
alors on le disait tout à l'heure vous
êtes un grand fan de michael jordan vous
aimez beaucoup aussi à lebron james je
crois oui après leur donne cette légende
james lebron james à ce que vous je sais
pas beaucoup copié un petit peu de temps
en temps dans certains de vos gestes par
exemple amqui de temps en temps c'est un
an qu'est-ce qu'on ait copié par exemple
basse et fédérer donc tels que j'aime
j'aime bien ce mouvement donc et je
marque beaucoup de paniers avec vous est
arrivé ensuite
récemment on peut le dire à l'entente le
chesnay-versailles retour dans les
yvelines c'est bien ça voilà c'est ça
donc je suis revenu dans les yvelines à
versailles donc qui a un bon projet pour
l'avenir et je suis aussi entraîneur des
jeunes des cadets de versailles vous
êtes arrivé en régionale une si je me
trompe pas vous voilà un an régionales
une après on est monté l'année où je
suis arrivé on
monter et
on allait vers nationale 3 qu'est ce qui
vous plaît finalement dans les yvelines
vous étiez à trappes vous revenez jouer
à l'entente le chesnay versailles vous
êtes un passionné des yvelines c'est un
peu votre vie c'est ma ville donc depuis
depuis 2000 2002 je suis là donc un peu
je travaille ici mes enfants sont là
donc voila a déjà des listes à trappes à
trappes et je travaille dans la ville
aussi donc voilà j'ai vu passer des
générations et vous avez on disait un
quarante deux ans maintenant pourtant
vous continuez à scorer il y a deux ans
avant l'épisode du coc vie de 19 vous
avez marqué plusieurs fois plus de 40
points par match comment vous
l'expliquez est ce que vous êtes un peu
comme le bon vin vous modifiez avec
l'âge
non mais bon après c'est c'est tout un
travail donc comme l'équipe vous faisait
confiance la balle passait beaucoup par
à l'intérieur donc on joue à l'intérieur
et que après à la réussite elle devrait
incite qui fait que je marquais beaucoup
donc voilà j'ai
su marquer plusieurs jets parti
plusieurs fois 40 points et donc du coup
j'ai terminé meilleur marqueur de la
nationale 3 toute la france donc il ya
deux ans est ce que c'est un club qui
vous donne confiance aussi oui oui qu'on
fait ensuite c'est important pour moi
est la confiance oui c'est très
important parce que arrive la confiance
tu fais c'est que ce que tu vas faire
vous avez également réussi de belles
choses avec l'équipe nationale
sénégalaise oui donc j'ai été
sélectionné au moins 15 15 15 heures
soit 6 fois c'est ça et donc du coup
j'ai fait les championnats d'afrique et
les jeux africains et les qualifications
pour les championnats d'afrique mais
aussi et donc voila c'était c'était bien
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous de
porter ce maillot ah ben c'est à ça
représente beaucoup parce que
toutes les basketteurs rêve de porter
leur maillot de leur pays est ce qu'à un
moment particulier qui
vous a ému peut-être la première fois la
tête vous avez mis le maillot sénégalais
oui la première fois je me rappelle
c'est que entités en 99 si je me
rappelle si je me rappelle bien bien
avant le
sénégal ont été championnes en afrique
sera lente et champion d'afrique et
[Musique]
on allait en angola et c'est moi qui
avaient la cote parce que à l'époque
l'équipe qui gagne la coupe pas ramené
sur le prochain et l'armée et comme le
plus jeune
tenez la coupe donc c'était moi donc
voilà ça c'est des choses qui me
marquent cette expérience en équipe
nationale est ce que ça vous a permis de
progresser aussi en tant qu'homme
peut-être dans le basket après oui oui
oui ça m'a permis de gagner beaucoup
d'expérience beaucoup bon côté de ce
père trappe ou si ça vous a permis de
grandir on disait à cet envoi la trappe
sept ans
vous avez également vous avez également
l'association sauf hadji vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus oui
l'association sauf hadji donc voilà je
vais créer depuis 2017 et donc c'est les
initiales de mes enfants donc ça on a
fait les livres il est donc voilà donc
on oeuvre dans le social au sénégal on a
beaucoup les jeunes et on organise des
camps le basket c'est important pour
vous de transmettre aussi c'est à
travers le basket certaines valeurs
peut-être oui franchement celui parce
que avia le basket ça m'ouvre les portes
de pour pouvoir aider tous les jeunes et
de transmettre aussi tout ce que j'ai
appris au basket et faire beaucoup de
social et et cette année aussi on a nagé
la chance d'avoir une personne qui a
adhéré
l'association donc cécile qui est
mécènes et partenaires et donc voilà
donc la
l'association commence à prendre
l'ampleur et pour qu'on puisse aider
tous les jeunes au sénégal on la salue
et du coup commence à s'organiser un
camp de basket sauf hadji oui encore un
bon c'est beaucoup de boulot car parce
que faire à la fois métier de basketteur
et oui le gsm j'essaie de cumuler mais
c'est pas facile mais heureusement que
j'ai beaucoup de bénévoles qui nous
aident dc heroes sénégal aussi pour
pouvoir faire un bon camp donc il y a
il ya trois ans on avait fait les deux
dernières années on n'a pas fait par
rapport à la pandémie et et franchement
c'était bien on avait regroupé au moins
300 jeunes facilement est ce qu'on peut
vous aider justement à organiser ses
camps a bien sûr bien sûr tout aidé et
je prends tout ce qu'on peut m'aider par
rapport à ça donc
il ya beaucoup de choses donc tout
retour tous niveaux de fournitures
scolaires donc voilà donc d
et des
matériels didactiques pour les pour les
jeunes basketteurs dernière question
très rapidement qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour l'avenir vous avez
42 ans normalement ça devrait être votre
dernière année je crois non normalement
sais pas encore normalement ces vingt
dernières années mais j'aimerais bien qu
être un bon formateur plus tard pour
transmettre mon savoir aux jeunes en
france au sénégal c'est important pour
l'instant ses adversaires merci beaucoup
bamba cei et bon courage pour la suite
de la saison en nationale 3 avec
l'entente le chesnay versailles merci
votre mobile
[Musique]